[Musique]
et pour en parler sur ce plateau bruno
megaman chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bon soir
bruno me garbade merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés philippe herlin économise
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être là et
puis nous irons également retrouvé un
petit peu plus tard thomas bonnet en
direct de washington où l'administration
maiden peine à imposer la vaccination
obligatoire dans les entreprises à tout
à l'heure thomas adam quelques minutes
on vous retrouvera alors l'europe
inquiets de re devenu le moteur
malheureusement de la pandémie la france
est dans sa cinquième vague
officiellement a dit olivier ferrand
c'était prévisible selon vous où bruno
meyer ban comment on peut l'expliquer
d'ailleurs puisque l'europe est parmi
les plus vacciner alors on va dire
c'était prévisible mais peut-être pas
avec la même amplitude c'était
prévisible oui parce que le virus n'a
pas de raison de disparaître de la
planète et qu'avec le refroidissement
des températures
le fait que nous revivons à l'intérieur
sans ouvrir les fenêtres qu'on reprenne
une pleine activité sociale et de
loisirs est bien faisait que le virus
allait pouvoir se propager maintenant
effectivement on pensait au début que le
vaccin pourrait mieux freiner les
contaminations même si on sait qu'il
protège parfaitement contre les formes
graves de la maladie on pensait qu'il
pouvait freiner davantage les
contaminations et donc réduire la
diffusion du virus et peut-être même
protéger les personnes non vaccinées
malheureusement nous devons constater
qu'effectivement malgré la vaccination
les contaminations peuvent se faire même
si comme vous le savez une personne
vaccinée contaminé fera une forme bien
moins sévère que s'ils n'avaient pas été
vaccinés alors face à sa cinquième vague
en viens de le dire
et voisins européens prennent des
mesures l'allemagne qui annonce un pass
sanitaire qui s'appelle pas comme ça
mais enfin ça revient au même les non
vaccinés seront exclues de certains
lieux publics en autriche on confine
carrément les non vaccinés il ya des
éléments d'ailleurs qui vont jusqu'à
1450 euros avec beaucoup de contrôler
votre réaction philippe herlin moi j'ai
assez scandalisé par ce convoi je crois
qu'on est dans une comédie sanitaires il
faut revenir au fait il faut il faut
bien entendre la déclaration qu'a fait
jean françois delfraissy hier qu'elle
président du conseil scientifique il a
dit que les vaccins protègent assez peu
de la contamination du site ces termes
exacts donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça mais
ça veut dire que le l'obligation
vaccinale masqué en fait que l'on voit
avec avec le pass à lithaire
l'obligation vaccinale n'a pas de sens
obligation vaccinale pour les personnels
de santé n'a pas de sens non plus parce
que vous pouvez à vous pouvez avoir être
vaccinés et puis transmettre quand même
la maladie donc il vaut mieux que les
personnels de santé soient testés
régulièrement plutôt que d'être obligé
d'être vacciné le l'obligation d'athina
son camp fait pour les adultes les
adolescents et on pense on envisage de
faire pour les enfants des aucun sens
parce que on nous explique à wayne l'isf
en bonne santé donc ils vont pas faire
de formes graves les enfants feu 0 forme
grave les seuls qui sont morts c'est
qu'avec obésité mais ils peuvent la
transmettre dans kg mais il est vacciné
mais non mais si le vaccin n'empêche pas
la contamination quel intérêt de
vacciner les enfants les adolescents et
les adultes en bonne santé je rappelle
un chiffre de santé publique france les
moins de 65 ans sans comorbidités ça
représente seulement 2% des décès ça
veut dire que quand on est en bonne
santé on n'est pas concerné directement
par le cos vide il faut respecter les
barrières mais mais mais il n'y a pas de
moi je remets en cause aussi la notion
confinement on a fait beaucoup trop et
pour moi il n'ya pas c'est pas du gtx
sanitaires qui sont pour ce motif
politique c'est une étatisation de
l'économie c'est là une sorte de coup
d'état contre les population qui impose
des directives complètement débile comme
le fait d'en fermer les confiner dans
fait d'enfermer les non vaccinés j'ai
aussi vu qu'il ya des préfets qui
commence a obligé en france à m remettre
le mas à l'extérieur alors qu'on sait
que ça sert il n'y a aucune étude n'a
jamais montré que le match à l'extérieur
fonctionner mais c'est un discours de
peur pour imposer
des décisions étatiques et mettre les
gens sous l'étouffoir et je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux c'est un problème
de liberté publique ça n'a plus rien à
voir avec un discours sanitaires on va
voir cette première réaction au
télégramme à combien de recevoir
j'espère qu'elle va s'afficher dans
quelques instants copap la cata voilà
qui nous dit non ce n'est pas sept
heures élection c'est pas celle de
michel qui a beaucoup voyagé ces la
vaccination ne protège pas de la
contagiosité de la maladie certes elles
diminuent peut-être les cas graves mais
actuellement nous remarquons qu'il ya
autant vacciner que de nom vacciner dans
les hôpitaux bono megaman ça c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai il ya désormais plus de
vacciner que de nom vacciner chez vous à
la cie pitié salpêtrière par exemple
alors tout d'abord rétablissement de la
vérité donc la vaccin sûr réduit la
contamination de troie d'un facteur 3
effectivement ce n'est pas suffisant
pour empêcher les contaminations mais ça
l'a réduit deuxièmement la vaccination
réduit le risque d'être hospitalisée par
un facteur 10 à 11 donc c'est énorme
donc aujourd'hui dans mon service de
réanimation médicale il n'y a aucune
personne vaccinée donc fightnews ce ne
sont que des personnes non vaccinées
d'ailleurs souvent qui ont peu de
comorbidité c'est là le point important
c'est à dire il faut pas penser qu'en
n'ayant pas de commande vides et entend
plutôt jeune et bien on ne risque pas de
faire la maladie cas malheureusement
effectivement les personnes non
vaccinées
se croyant protégés adoptent le mode de
vie des personnes vaccinées et c'est là
qu'ils attrapent le covin parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui le virus
circule un niveau élevé et
malheureusement pour eux ils ne sont pas
vaccinés ça la caractéristique donc il
s'expose à un risque qui n'est pas nul
alors qui est peut-être plus faible chez
les laissant comme envie d'aimer qui
n'est pas nul de faire une forme grave
de la maladie et de mourir et c'est là
où c'est dommage parce qu'ils ont une
âme qui est le vaccin qui leur
permettrait justement d'éviter ce risque
de façon extrêmement importante
fini par là quand vous entendez voilà
ses explications assez rationnelle d'un
médecin qu'est ce que vous répondez vous
êtes en plus économistes vous avez
certainement vu que l'économie continue
d'un pays est-ce que soit j'imagine
aussi tous les états qu est ce que vous
vous répondez à ces arguments mais le
vaccin diminue les formes graves ça
c'est ces mesures est constaté et les
gens qui sont touchés par les formats
graz et des personnes âgées ou les
personnes qu'on est qu'au bord bilité
donc ça justifie pas d'avoir une
politique sanitaire aussi et de brutal
où on va enfermer les non-vaccinés quoi
voilà donc ces et puis sur les chiffres
alors sur les chiffres vous dit que je
n'avais aucun aucun non vaccinés a aucun
vacciner au malade aujourd'hui bon c'est
pas du tout les chiffres qu'on voit en
angleterre dans d'autres pays en france
c'est vrai quoi les gars on dit qu'il ya
quasiment aucun malade
vaccinées en france bon et on la france
est peut-être complètement à part les
autres pays européens mais ça m'étonne
mais c'est pas du tout les chiffres
qu'on a un réseau pays le vaccin protège
contre les formes graves mais pas de
façon parfaite donc il ya aussi des
risques et moi je considère alors même
si le vaccin protège compter forme grave
je considère qu'il faut aussi penser aux
traitements à ce que moi j'ai attrapé le
vide je répète qu reid et j'ai été
guérie parce qu'un médecin a bien voulu
me feel it de l'ivermectine
l'érythromycine la fièvre est tombée à
24 heures et en trois jours je tirais
établi voilà donc donc ces traitements
là on sait que ça marche il ya des pays
toute l'afrique noire l'afrique
subsaharienne sauf l'afrique du sud où
on utilise beaucoup les vermines chine
parce qu'il ya des questions de pas lu
tout ça il ya ils n'ont pas du tout été
touchés alors aussi bien macron que la
meyze nous disent il faut vacciner
l'afrique etc eux ils n'ont pas de
problème voilà donc il faut aussi penser
aux traitements c'est complémentaire
mais considérait plus vaccin est la
seule et unique solution et qu'il faut
forcer les gens à se vacciner ça ne ce
n'est pas possible parce qu'on voit que
ce sont les pays très vaccinés qui
subissent une augmentation des cas alors
si c'est que les cas c'est pas grave
mais aussi une augmentation du nombre de
malades donc ça veut dire que ses
papattes la solution unique il faut
avoir une palette de deux traitements
différents relevés
sur les nouveaux traitements mais on va
laisser répondre je sens que plus d'un
milliard avaient envie de répondre alors
d'abord effectivement oui il y à des
personnes vaccinées qui développent une
forme plus grave de la maladie qui sont
admis à l'hôpital nous n'en avons eu
dans notre service mais ce sont des
personnes qui soit ont une
immunodépression qui fait qu'ils
répondent mal aux vaccins soient
effectivement aujourd'hui on le sait
qu'avec le temps par rapport à la
deuxième dose s'il s'est passé plus de
six mois il y a une certaine baisse de
la protection c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
il faut pour pouvoir éviter ça instaurer
deux points le premier c'est la dose de
rappel pour toutes les personnes à
risque et notamment de plus de 65 ans
six mois après
double dose et puis surtout vacciner le
plus grand nombre car les personnes qui
ne peuvent pas recevoir le vaccin pour
des raisons médicales ou qui sont
immunodéprimés et qui ne répondent pas
aux vaccins seront protégés du fait que
la circulation du virus dans la
population vaccinée sera moindre c'est
pourquoi il est important de vacciner y
compris certaines personnes qui n'ont
peut-être pas directement leur ait un
risque de faire une forme grave de la
maladie
ensuite concernant les traitements
qu'après mon collègue et ami je dirais
malheureusement ça n'est pas les
traitements qu'ils ont guéri c'est
simplement lui même il n'a pas de
facteur de commanditer il est jeune il a
fait une forme mineure de la maladie il
a guéri spontanément ils auraient pris
de l'eau sucrée du coca cola il aurait
guéri de l'ami de la même façon avec la
même vie tu fais pas mon cas pour ak
médical et ses personnels mais mais
c'est aussi d'essayer aussi des études
qui montrent que ces traitements
fonctionnent il ya des pistes mans il
ya les souhaits pays d'afrique il ya
l'inde qui règle les problèmes aussi
avec les ratings le japon aussi qu
utilisent ce produit la qualité très peu
touché donc non il ya quand même des
études qui le montre voilà donc alors
les différences entre les pays que vous
évoquez bien sûr il existe c'est que
vous heureusement pour le continent
africain sont une population beaucoup
plus jeunes
avec moins de co morbidités alors qu'en
europe malheureusement dans une
population vieillissante avec le diabète
avec des problèmes cardiovasculaires
avec un mode de vie en milieu fermé clos
et donc tout ça favorise la diffusion du
virus et malheureusement le
développement de formes plus grave ça
veut dire à bruno v germann que selon
vous la fin justifie les moyens quand on
voit que l'autriche confine les
non-vaccinés amont l'autriche qui
plafonne effectivement qui plafonnait à
65% et qui d'ailleurs se précipitant
maintenant voilà c'est cocasse avoir
vers les centres de vaccination ça veut
dire que il faut en passer par là sous
peine voilà deux un petit coup de canif
aux libertés fondamentales individuelles
alors je suis pas persuadé qu'il faille
confiner les non vaccinés je crois que
c'est vraiment une mesure extrême
d'ailleurs elle n'a lieu que lorsque
effectivement en raison de la poussée
épidémique
si la couverture vaccinale est
extrêmement médiocre certains
gouvernements arrive à cet extrême mais
en fait on peut parfaitement l'éviter en
améliorant la couverture vaccinale ce
qui est le cas de la france actuellement
donc il est très peu probable qu en
france on soit amené à en arriver à ces
extrêmes globalement peu efficace je
pense c'est bien mieux de modifier le
pass sanitaire actuel vers un pass
vaccinale qui poussera peut-être
davantage les hésitants à se faire
vacciner et puis ceux qui sont
totalement réfractaires malheureusement
on pourra pas les faire vacciner c'est
leur droit mais je mon conseil amical
pour eux pour qu'ils restent en vie et
bien qu'ils appliquent strictement les
mesures barrières ça qu'ils n'auront pas
le droit de sortir le bout du nez de
leurs masques car malheureusement ils
risqueraient de tomber malade et
gravement malade et l'ayant eu j'ai une
immunité naturelle qui est meilleure que
celle des vaccins donc il ya des
millions de français qui sont dans ce
cas là donc pourquoi est-ce que la
sérologie n'est pas reconnue dans le
système dans cette politique sanitaire
que l'on voit il ya des millions de
français qui
ils ont une unité qui est meilleur voilà
donc alors qu'ida plus longtemps que les
vaches alors d'abord on va dire que les
effectivement vous avez raison lorsqu'on
a fait l'infection naturelle mais qu'on
a reçu une dose de vaccin une seule dose
de vaccin là on a l'immunité la
meilleure c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'immunité hybride par contre si on a
juste fait l'infection naturelle une
fois on a une immunité qui diminue avec
le temps comme les personnes qui ont
doublement été vaccinées en fait
procéder la dose de 25 peut-être que
vous avez reçus ou pas je ne sais pas on
sert de booster suite à votre infection
est effectivement à ce moment là vous
seriez aujourd'hui dans le meilleur
cadre de la protection maintenant à
nouveau je répète pour vous vous êtes
plutôt jeune et en bonne santé donc vous
risquez peu de faire une forme grave de
la maladie mais pensons quand on diffuse
des messages contre la vaccination aux
personnes plus crédules qui nous
écoutent et qui l ont des vrais risques
de faire des formes graves de la maladie
et bien malheureusement il se retrouve
chez nous et là ils constatent amèrement
et à leurs dépens que s'il avait été
vacciné il ne serait pas venu en
réanimation philippe herlin selon un
sondage 1 et là bas pour bfmtv l'express
près de six français sur dix tout de
même son sont favorables à reconfirme
des personnes non vaccinées comme le
fait l'autriche ça vous évoque quoi
parce que c'est vrai beaucoup de
personnes vaccinées n'ont pas envie
entre guillemets d'être les seuls
finalement le vrai pour la collectivité
aussi ça vous comprenez ce sentiment
mais je trouve ça assez effrayant parce
que c'est la fabrique du bouc émissaire
quand on présente les non-vaccinés com
dcom comme les responsables du problème
et les vaccinés en tout cas beaucoup de
vacciner en sont convaincus le problème
c'est que s'il se penche sur les apps
les thèmes que je viens d'évoquer
environ que le vaccin peut pas être la
seule solution surtout qu'il ya un autre
aspect évoqué dont on parle assez peu
mais quand commence à en parler ça
commence à émerger ce sont les effets
secondaires bon on sait qu'à des
myocarde et des problèmes cardiaques qui
touche un certain nombre des personnes
qui sont jeunes en bonne santé il ya
plein d'athlètes de footballeurs
notamment ça a été recensée par des par
les journalistes qui sont cons des
problèmes en un match ça fait des
dizaines de personnes dans l'est dans
les ligues professionnelles ou amateurs
on on sait qu'il ya quand même des décès
aussi alors il ya la base au drague
gilles ans qui parle de 20000 évidemment
c'est pas ces défis cas présumés cire
des gens quand ils sont décédés après le
vaccin c'est pas forcément le vaccin qui
la cause pour le savoir fois référé
toxiques le problème c'est qu'en fait
pas d'autopsié comme ça on est sûr de ne
pas le savoir et on cherche j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche un peu à
masquer sa il ya des effets secondaires
importants et donc pour moi ça rentre
d'autres la vaccination des jeunes et
des adultes en bonne santé d'autant plus
irrationnel qu'on vaccine le vaccin ne
me protège contre les personnes âgées et
les personnes calicoba bilité ça diminue
nettement la spécialisation est d'accord
les vacciner les personnes en bonne
santé compte tenu fait cas des risques
pour moi la balance bénéfice risque elle
est négative pour les enfants les
adolescents et les et les adultes en
bonne santé donc il faut pas vacciner
tout le monde avant d'aller au portugal
c'est important que vous répondiez parce
que ça c'est peut-être aussi le
sentiment pour beaucoup de français
effectivement je les jeunes il faut bien
le dire et là on commence à voir les
pays qui vacciner 5 11 ans est ce bien
nécessaire d'ailleurs le conseil
aujourd'hui khademi canaliser bah on va
pas sacrifier entre guillemets les
enfants pour protéger les adultes qui
ont pas envie de se faire vacciner alors
tout d'abord il faut bien sûr vous
l'avez reconnu le vaccin est efficace
quelle que soit la classe dash
maintenant effectivement non le vaccin
c'est un médicament donc de fait il a
des effets secondaires donc évidemment
il peut donner par exemple à risque de
mieux car dit qui est plus important
avec le vaccin moderne a par exemple les
plus importants chez l'homme jeune ça
c'est tout à fait mais le problème c'est
que si cet homme jeune attrape la coved
naturellement eh bien il a plus de
risques de faire une myocardite que par
le vaccin est d'ailleurs s'il fait la
myocardite au cours de l'infection
naturelle et les plus graves que s'il
l'a fait à la suite du vaccin les mots
car dit on les voyait pas avant certains
médias d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que
c'est pas l'heure du monde est donné
jamais lyon mais je vous rappelle que
j'ai enfin pu me donner la pape leur
seront donnés le rock in de notre ami
professeur à olten a beaucoup des
patients qui avaient l'aco vide on l'a
accusée d'avoir des effets secondaires
cardiaques mais ça n'était pas du tout
les dropkick le rugby c'est parce qu'on
le donnait à des patients qui avaient
des problèmes cardiaques du fun de l'aco
vide c'est la maladie sous jacente qui a
fait émerger un risque éventuel d'effets
secondaires à l'hydro de cyclos routine
mais si on va faire un détour vers le
portugal 1 où on assiste aussi à un
petit rebond des contaminations pourtant
parmi les plus weixing d'europe et même
du monde avec 85% du schéma complet le
pays envisage de nouvelles restrictions
non pas avec pia il n psychologue
clinicienne en direct donc de lisbonne
bonsoir pilat il n merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord quelle est la
situation sanitaire dans le pays on
parle d'art d'un rebond
et il se passe très bien aussi au
portugal comme vous savez bien il ya eu
entre cibles et la situation sanitaire
dans la rue et que il ya du respect les
gens se sont inclinés ce fonctionne
vacciner et c'est l'armée qui a aidé à
faire ça c'est vrai le portugal n'est
pas toujours un pays qui si bien
organisée mais en ce qui concerne la
vaccination ça a été mais impressionnant
mans efficace et il n'y a pas cette
dilemme à ces discussions si les non
vaccinés ne pourront pas rentrer ici ou
par là non il ya un peu la mentalité
surtout cg les jeunes que oui et la
vaccination est nécessaire c'est
obligatoire on le fait pour se protéger
nous et pour protéger la société il n'y
a pas il ya beaucoup moins d'hésitation
il ya moins de préoccupation et il ya
moins d abstinence dans les vaccinations
il ya peut-être un esprit qui fait que
oui on va pouvoir faire ça ici mme
portugal et oui vous avez raison c'est
arrivé et ça se présente plutôt bien
même si oui les chiffres c'est plus que
2000 affectés aujourd'hui et il va avoir
un look tendance et aux as et bientôt un
autre problème du local c'est que ce
n'est pas populaire et le premier
ministre comme cost oui son budget n'a
pas passé ce qui veut dire il est pas
très très bien assise et conduire à des
élections tout début d'année il n'a pas
encore parlé du logo c'était le premier
ministre lui qui maintenant comment
savoir les du local parce que c'est vrai
que les chiffres sont très très très
haut et ça a créé tout le monde avec
même 85 points sont vaccinés que ça
puisse continuer à cette
vitesse oui oui ce film c'est super il
faut aussi préciser puis à ghislaine que
le système hospitalier au portugal est
extrêmement fragile donc c'est une forme
de nécessité aussi peut-être pour les
portugais de se protéger
gfr incliné vous voulez dire quand est
ce que comme ça en soit par les
restrictions soient par les gestes
barrière ou par la vaccination au choix
mais il ya un système hospitalier qui
est fragile
c'est vrai les hôpitaux publics qui
normalement on fonctionne très très bien
il ya un très bon dieu service social
hôpitaux les gens sont bien aimé ici
avec le cog hill on est débordé c'est
vrai il ya eu des gens qui dépassent et
dans des tentes dehors
partout en europe se résume ça a été
très difficile dans nos hôpitaux publics
et ils ont commencé à envoyer les
patients dans les hôpitaux privés comme
ça peut-être ça va pouvoir partager un
peu ce poids qui est venue la sidam ans
et qui on est obligé de atteindre tout
de suite deux sont occupés du traité les
gens
merci il ya il n pour ce rapide panorama
de la situation au portugal vous ne
m'ayez he man on était un petit peu
ébahie d'entendre effectivement 85% de
vacciner pourtant on parle de l'homme
donne au portugal alors déjà c'est vrai
qu'avec 85% vacciner pourquoi on parle
maintenant de confiner aussi la base
c'est vrai que là c'est un petit peu la
double peine si j'ose dire alors je ne
sais pas quelle en est la décision de
confinement ou pas au portugal en tout
cas on en parle mais en tout cas l'une
des caractéristiques de cette bague
c'est qu'il y à un découplage entre les
contaminations qui progresse de façon
exponentielle qui vont atteindre un
niveau que l'on n'a jamais atteint au
cours des vagues précédentes puisqu'il
n'y a aucune mesure de restriction
chacun peut circuler comme il veut
chacun peut aller dans dans la réunion
qu'il veut
et donc les contaminations vont
progresser par contre il y aura un
découplage par rapport aux
hospitalisations et ce découplage sera
d'autant meilleure que la couverture
vaccinale est élevé et donc c'est très
clairement le cas du portugal et de
l'espagne pour une très bonne couverture
vaccinale ça sera aussi le cas en france
c'est pourquoi on est malgré tout
relativement optimiste en comparaison
aux vagues précédentes c'est moins le
cas des pays de l'est qui l'a le
découplage n'est pas aussi clair et de
fait malgré tout il faut être prudent
car lorsque les contaminations vont
augmenter si elle atteint le niveau trop
élevé du fait qu' il y a encore par
exemple en france au moins 15% des
personnes qui devaient se faire vacciner
qui ne le sont pas eh bien on risquerait
avec ces personnes parfaitement
d'encombrés l'hôpital c'est pourquoi il
faut absolument respecter les mesures
barrières et faire tout pour réduire la
circulation du virus mais de toute façon
on observe déjà et on observa à tout
instant un découplage jamais on
connaîtra l'afflux massif de patients à
l'hôpital qui fera que le gouvernement
n'aura pas le choix que de faire un
confinement sauvegarder la santé de la
population on va aller maintenant encore
plus loin en outre atlantique à la
campagne vaccinale rencontre quelques
difficultés on y retrouve donc thomas
bonne et notre correspondant à
washington thomas le président américain
qui a dû abandonner la vaccination
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 100 salariés
oui cette mesure a été suspendue c'était
la dernière mesure en date décidée par
joe biden pour tenter d'accélérer la
campagne vaccinale qui patine aux états
unis il ya moins de 60% de la population
américaine qui est complètement vaccinés
au moment où je vous parle alors joe
biden avait donc décidé d'instaurer
cette mesure qui concerne des millions
d'américains tous ceux qui travaillent
dans des entreprises de plus de 100
salariés une obligation de vaccination à
partir du 4 janvier prochain ou à défaut
d'une prof de vaccination un test qui
doit être réalisée de manière
hebdomadaire alors dès l'annoncé de
cette mesure par le gouvernement
américain il a eu beaucoup de poursuites
et qui ont été lancés par des états aux
états unis pour tenter de bloquer cette
mesure ça a donc fonctionné puisque une
cour d'appel fédérale a suspendu cette
mesure de joe biden au motif qu'elle
pose de sérieux problèmes
constitutionnels on assiste donc à un
bras de fer juridique qui pourrait
s'achever auprès de la cour suprême des
etats unis la plus haute juridiction du
pays qui va donc sans doute devoir
trancher sur cette question est ce que
le gouvernement américain a le droit
d'imposer une obligation de vaccination
dans le pays alors le timing est assez
forte puisque je vous le disais cette
mesure était censée entrer en
application le 4 janvier prochain le
gouvernement
joe biden en tout cas en apparence se
montre toujours optimiste explique
toujours que cette mesure est nécessaire
pour protéger davantage d'américains il
explique d'ailleurs que le retard de la
mise en place de cette mesure pourrait
provoquer des dizaines voire des
centaines de décès dans le pays alors
cette mise en place de l'obligation de
vaccination on le voit est donc très
compliqué aux états unis où évidemment
les libertés individuelles sont très
importantes pour les américains
notamment vous restez avec nous pour
aborder la dernière partie du débat tout
à l'heure avec la question des
traitements très en pointe en ce moment
aux états unis philippe herlin ça vous
fait rêver évidemment cette cour d'appel
qui parle d'un abus de pouvoir
inconstitutionnelle de joe biden on
pourrait voir peut-être la même chose
devant les tribunaux en france selon
vous j'espère bien le problème c'est que
la cause le conseil conditionnelle
français les conseils d'état se sont
couchés devant gouvernement donc il faut
à rien d'espérer 2 contrairement aux
états unis où il ya manifestement un peu
plus de l'indépendance de la justice bon
mais les serments tout ça le cas de
l'espagne avec 85% vaccination ça montre
que le vaccin peut pas être la seule
solution est et je le répète il ya les
le cas des effets secondaires qui sont
en train de remonter qui sont quand même
masqué statistiquement parce que quand
il y avait un mort du co vie d'avant
même si le mec avait un cancer ou une
maladie grave s'il est testé positif qu
vide on disait qu'il était mort du co
ville c'est pour ça qu'on se retrouve
avec 135 mille morts en france 2 comme
id alors que les chiffres elle en italie
ils ont recalculé les chiffres et les
gens qui sont morts uniquement du coc
vide c'est 3% tous les autres étaient
morts d'autres choses avec deux avec
d'autres comorbidités donc quand on fait
un peu exprès de déjà géré les choses et
et bon voilà donc c'est pas possible de
de rester dans ce schéma de vaccins
comme solution unique justement quand
bondir sur ces chiffres parce qu'il ya
une nouvelle hier qu'ils étaient assez
étonnante on nous dit 5 millions de
morts sur la planète et plusieurs études
c'est paru hier vous l'avez certainement
vu nous disent que ces chiffres
pourraient être sous-estimée ça pourrait
être trois fois supérieure alors qui a
raison qui a tort dans cette affaire
l'avis du médecin alors je peux
certifier que toutes les personnes ou
les 120000 peu près décès en france sont
directement liés aux coûts vide alors
effectivement certains avec quelques cow
mobilité mais ils ne sont pas décédées
de l'évolution fatale de leur maladie
mais de la décompensation de leur
maladie à cause de la colorisation
estimé nous allons très clairement
sous-estimé dans le monde évidemment
dans tous les pays même en afrique dans
sa faible en chine vous imaginez en
chine il ya très peu de morts mais
évidemment il y en a bien plus vous
pouvez mettre plusieurs zéros à côté du
chiffre de départ donc c'est largement
sous-estimé à mon avis même trois fois
le chiffre annoncé est probablement en
deçà de la vérité alors on va retourner
voir thomas puisqu'il ya peut-être de
quoi mettre tout le monde d'accord en
tout cas rassuré ceux qui ne sont pas
vraiment favorable aux vaccins thomas
puisque aux états unis l'apparition d'un
traitement développé par plusieurs
laboratoires
est en train donc d'être d'être
clairement développé
oui la maison blanche croit beaucoup en
ses traitements pour preuve washington a
commandé 10 millions de traitements à
pfizer de ce traitement qui s'appelle
donc le pacs le vide à 10 millions de
traitements commandé par la maison
blanche pour une somme avoisinant 5 9 5
29 1 milliards de dollars alors c'est un
traitement qui est donc commercialisé
par pfizer il s'agit de 30 comprimés à
prendre dans une période de cinq jours
alors le kaiser a montré des résultats
intermédiaires sur les tests pour ce
traitement il affirme qu'il y à
l'efficacité de l'ordre de 89 % pour
réduire les hospitalisations et les
décès pour les adultes qui sont à risque
il ya aussi un autre acteur sur le
marché de ces traitements c'est
l'entreprise merck là aussi washington a
déjà commandé des traitements puisqu'il
y avait là 3,1 millions de traitements
qui ont été commandés par la maison
blanche mais d'abord il va d'hommes il
va falloir que l'agencé américaine des
médicaments valide ces deux traitements
la décision devrait intervenir d'ici la
fin du mois de novembre merci thomas
philippe herlin une bonne nouvelle pour
les réticents aux vaccins que vous êtes
un d'ailleurs astrazeneca a annoncé un
tout à l'heure aux six mètres 1 un
traitement
allez c'est sûr c'était la solution
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est aussi le
monopole portail d'heure parce que comme
on vient de le voir ça extrêmement
coûteux beaucoup plus que l'hiver mais
tim powers donc si c'est au moins aussi
efficace solidaire meeting pourquoi pas
si ça allait un peu plus alors là c'est
formidable mais il faut attendre de voir
ici parce que quand le vaccin est sortie
on nous annonçait 95 % d'efficacité et
penseront qu'on s'est rendu compte après
qu elle diminué et que donc on va avoir
un abonnement vaccinale il faudra faire
des robes des piqûres tous les six mois
ou tous les ans à vie et quand on sait
je le rappelle qui a des effets
secondaires importants etc etc c'est
quelque chose qui cachent aujourd'hui
mais qui risque d'exploser un peu con
affaire du sang contaminé moi je dis
attention c'est une erreur de vacciner
de vouloir vacciner tout le monde il
faut réserver le vaccin qu'un efficacité
démontrée pour les cas fragile bruno
megaman cette pilule ça va nous empêcher
d'avoir ça va nous dispenser on va dire
d'avoir cette troisième dose peut-être
vous y croyez
d'abord repréciser les les vaccins n'ont
pas les fameux effets secondaires que
l'on décrit actuellement pour une fois
jamais un médicament un vaccin n'a été
n'a affiché aussi clairement et
publiquement les risques
aujourd'hui on a plus de 7 milliards
d'individus qui ont été vaccinés et tous
les effets secondaires potentiels qui
sont pour souvent uniquement une
coïncidence sont publiés donc vous
pouvez sûr que le vaccin est
parfaitement et efficace et on va dire
avec des effets secondaires extrêmement
fins d'arachide de ses effets
secondaires justement oui on va dire à
peu près les effets secondaires
principaux c'est des problèmes de
douleurs au bras aussi de vaccination
d'un petit syndrome viral mais qui sont
des effets secondaires habituel des
vaccins les effets secondaires un peu
plus graves qui peuvent survenir on va
dire dans les jours qui suivent la
vaccination li a effectivement la
myocardite il y à quelques effets
secondaires neurologiques
et puis il peut y avoir des problèmes
sur les plaquettes de thrombose mais ça
reste des événements extrêmement rare et
la balance bénéfice-risque rsa
extrêmement favorable maintenant quant
au traitement alors oui nous sommes
ravis évidemment qu'il y ait ces
nouveaux traitements d'ailleurs il ya
deux gammes de traitement il ya les
pilules anti viral dont on vient
discuter il ya quand même il faut le
rappeler les anticorps monoclonaux qui
existent déjà depuis un petit moment
alors la caractéristique de ces
traitements quels qu'ils soient ils ne
s'adressent qu'à la phase précoce de la
maladie c'est à dire la phase virale
donc il ne vise que les personnes dans
les trois à cinq jours après la
contamination donc tout au début une
fois passé ce stade il ne marche plus du
tout donc une fois qu'on développe la
pneumonie ça ne marche pas du tout donc
d'abord faut-il encore se dépister et ce
diagnostic est très précocement ensuite
ils s'adressent surtout et d'abord est
quasiment uniquement aux personnes qui
ont un risque de faire une forme grave
de la maladie ce d'autant plus qu'ils ne
sont pas vaccinés voir s'ils sont
vaccinés évidemment et qu'ils ont été
contaminés car effectivement on sait que
lorsqu'on a des comorbidités lorsque la
une immunodépression malgré le vaccin
parfois on peut développer des formes
graves de manille donc c'est une
thérapeutique de sauvetage pour les
aider maintenant en aucun cas ça ne se
substitue à la vaccination donc il faut
pas penser justement comme comme ça a
été dit précédemment je ne me fais pas
vacciner j'attends d'être contaminés et
je prends ces comprimés car comme vous
le savez vous prenez un risque de
dépendre uniquement de comprimés que
vous allez prendre d'éviter la forme
grave de la maladie il vaut mieux malgré
tout éviter d'être infecté pour ne
jamais courir c'est triste ce risque
grave de la maladie merci vous n'aurez
pas ou certainement pas convaincu
philippe herlin que ce soir mais enfin
voilà comme d'habitude sur rt france on
donne toutes les opinions et bruno home
& garden merci il perd la merci à vous
aussi